what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on members of the Rob Kaur
welcome welcome to another thrilling
edition of how to kill superheroes we
are a murderous Bunch
today I want you to come with me on a
journey a journey to the bottom of the
sea that's right we're leaving the
comfort of dry land and venturing into
hostile territory to the underwater
Kingdom of Atlantis to kill its king
Arthur Currie better known as Aquaman
now there was a time not very long ago
when Aquaman was considered a
laughingstock of the DC Universe quickly
dismissed as the guy who talks to fish
admittedly I even share this view for a
long time but now Aquaman is no longer
the subject of mockery but is in fact
the best thing coming out of DC rebirth
this is compounded by the fact that we
got to see Jason Momoa as Aquaman riding
the Batmobile how awesome is that I saw
that scene in the trailer and I was just
like oh my god that looks amazing
Aquaman's riding the Batmobile Aquaman
zerbies like I feel like I'll go man
it's gonna be the best character in the
Justice League movie but despite how
awesome Jason Momoa may very well be as
Aquaman he still gotta die so let's get
right down to figuring out how to kill
Arthur curry so as always we're going to
start with a brief overview of the
character and followed that up with the
discussion of his powers so that we can
see why the proposition of killing
Aquaman presents us with such a
challenge now as we get around to our
overview of the character I want to
point out that since the character of
Aquaman has been around for a very long
time he's had multiple versions of his
origin published throughout history but
we are going to be focusing on the
current version of Aquaman which is also
the version that debuted in the new 52
Aquaman series in 2011 so this version
of Aquaman is actually half human and
half Atlantean a subspecies of humans
that have adapted to survive underwater
with his father being a man named Tom
curry and his mother being an Atlantean
named Atlanta now because of his
Atlantean physiology Aquaman develops
powers and his lair boded king of the
underwater Kingdom of Atlantis after its
previous king died leaving no heirs to
the throne in addition to serving as
Atlantean royalty
Aquaman spends a lot of his time on the
mainland United States where he spent
his childhood and where he also fights
crime as
hero and was a founding member of the
Justice League now as far as Aquaman's
powers go as I said earlier they go far
beyond talking to fish which technically
isn't even one of his powers however he
can communicate with sea life
telepathically and can summon animals
from great distances to his location
however it has been explained in the new
52 aquaman comments that fish and other
sea creatures are not intelligent enough
to carry on an actual conversation so
Aquaman can basically just
telepathically send signals to their
brains and they just do whatever it is
that he wants them to do so he can
control fish using telepathy but he
can't really talk to them but even so
this isn't even Aquaman's most
impressive ability not only does the
fact that he's habit lanten allow
aquaman to breathe underwater as well as
survive the immense pressure of the deep
but it also allows him in heightened
senses of vision hearing and smell he
also possesses superhuman strength that
allows him to lift 150 times the normal
human maximum which is up to about 60
tons and he's displayed his strength
several times
lifting large ships and throwing them on
more than one occasion now in the DC
rebirth Aquaman's series we've even seen
Arthur curry go toe-to-toe with Superman
during a fight and so even though
Aquaman is not typically thought of as
one of the strongest characters and DC
Comics his strength is not something we
can afford to take lightly
now Aquaman's strength is complemented
by superhuman speed especially when he's
moving underwater as he's been able to
swim faster than a high-speed jet flying
through the air as well as superhuman
durability as he's taken punches from
super-powered beings like Wonder Woman
and even sustained gunfire from an
automatic weapon without taking any
damage whatsoever he also possesses a
regenerative healing factor which he
used when stabbed through the chest with
a trident by the dead king Atlin and
healed within minutes now in addition
all of this Aquaman is a master
tactician and also highly advanced and
hand-to-hand combat so the question
comes after all these feats and powers
how do we kill him well our starting
point is a weakness that we first
learned about way back in 1959 and
adventure Comics number 256 when it was
revealed that Aquaman would die if he
didn't come into contact with water for
more than an hour now prior to this
Aquaman's stories basically had him able
to stay out of water indefinitely and
while the story is following Avenger
Comics number two
56 meant that he had to come into
contact with water once every hour over
the years this has begun to go away
however within recent comics both the
new 52 and BC rebirth we have not seen
anything that suggests that Aquaman can
remain out of water indefinitely so
we're going to assume that we can still
use this weakness to our advantage with
that in mind what we're going to have to
do is figure out a way to separate
Aquaman from water for an extended
period of time
now that sounds easy enough but we have
to remember Aquaman isn't just going to
let us do that and it's going to be
tough for us to force our will on
someone with super strength speed and
enhance combat skills and it's in that
aspect that we find the key to Aquaman's
demise the trick is going to be taking
away Aquaman's desire to get to the
water but how do we do this well as
usual when we're looking to kill members
of the Justice League we need to look no
further than Batman himself that's right
and the Tower of Babel storyline we find
out that Batman has contingencies in
place should he need to take out every
member of the Justice League besides
himself because as Batman fans will tell
you Batman can do no wrong now Batman's
contingency for Aquaman was an altered
form of Scarecrow's fear toxin that made
Aquaman scared of water which in turn
would cause him to avoided and in time
would lead to his death of course that
all assumes that we encounter Arthur on
dry land and we can keep him away from
water but I said in the intro that we're
going to meet him on his turf which is
the ocean and so that begs the question
is there any way to kill him there well
even though Aquaman is extremely strong
there are several characters in DC that
are stronger the trouble is can any one
of those characters survive long enough
to beat Aquaman in a fight to the death
inside the ocean well the answer to this
is yes and we need to look no further
than Superman to find an example I feel
so terrible using Superman in this but
we have a choice Superman can survive
without food water or even air and he's
able to survive without oxygen in space
so we can surmise that he can survive
without it underwater as well but
suppose we're not Superman see a lot of
the guys thought I was going to be like
aw man Superman and that's it but
suppose we're not Superman and we don't
have access to him or
any of the other characters that could
just promo Aquaman to death how are we
going to kill him if we have to fight
him underwater well the simple answer is
to get him to leave once the toxin was
used on Aquaman by Ra's al Ghul who had
discovered Batman's plans his fear was
able to be overcome by the telepathy of
the Martian Manhunter
this suggests that Aquaman is
susceptible to telepathic attacks which
presents us with another way to
influence Arthur into avoiding water
which of course would lead to his death
so hopefully we're able to Ally
ourselves with someone who can
telepathically influence Aquaman to
leave the ocean that might seem like a
bit of a cop-out but hey he's not the
king of Atlantis for nothing so killing
him in the water is next to impossible
so we simply just have to use every
trick at our disposal honestly guys we
kind of had to take this route we kind
of had to take this route it's Aquaman
you can't beat him in his home turf you
can't beat him in the ocean
the dude is a beast not to mention he's
got the physical prowess of Jason Momoa
if you've ever seen that picture of
Jason Momoa with his two bodyguards it's
a really intimidating picture one of
those bodyguards going to do I don't
even know why they're there like they're
just there for decoration I have no idea
anyway if you guys are new here to come
as explained wish you guys have the sub
button did he come part of the Rob core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I have no idea
who we're gonna kill the next video so
as we always do every couple weeks or so
post a character down below let me know
who you think we should kill should we
kill like venom like the Venom symbiote
because I'm sitting there trying to
think of people that we could kill we've
largely stuck with Marvel and DC so
maybe we should like kill spawn remember
we should kill like like bloodshot or
somebody from from Valiant Comics I have
no idea but post a comment down below
and we will figure out a way to fill
those characters we're gonna kill Chuck
Norris the next video we're going to
kill Chuck Norris Chuck Norris in real
life I promise no harm will come to you
but we're gonna see if it's possible to
kill Chuck Norris there we go
anyway we're gonna bring this video to
an end and I will catch you guys later
please know here's something we hope
you'll really like Chris is in there
really hope there's no too much poop on
the train
in addition because of cooling I'm
falling apart
yeah we turn up oh we want you ghastly
happily you guys can't use actually like
wood-burning fireplaces but it does make
sense because of course before what the
[ __ ] strawberry that actually sounds
like really good that I did yeah yeah I
was going to say I'm kind of your techie
producing you guys are all falling in
your old like our team has come together
up and then there's Dan there's a little
beer oh yeah oh that's - Daisy roll down
here roll dance
they call me be rolled and rolled I feel
like that sounds like a world of
warcraft boss telogen time beer all dad
waves coming out
[Laughter]
don't don't let your dreams be nice guy
or normal elbow you can look like here
don't see that right now when I'm to be
looking at a clock all right the other
printer you are stupid me up some point
me doing it and that would man en route
to a lot of joy I know there's a present
for this so originally in the 1940
Batman TP use guns to achieve his goals
you know he was an older comical go so
we can say that that was ignored later
when they decided to be more
family-friendly fun it has been used in
a more rigid year you seen Arkham Knight
he had a family that has riot
compression bullets on it and those both
freeze to shoot at people but they were
like mean bags and stuff like that but
even in more recent images I know that
much that's what you see back in gun to
shoot the dirtiness and every exciting
enough he went ahead grab their guns
shooting other people and then there was
the main long lease is how I remember it
so what I'm telling you is Batman can
use guns as long as they're special ammo
or somebody else has them to your
children you're going to use fire yeah
on a dim world by robbers yeah
that was amazing
oh my god
that was excellent okay so we got
I can't believe about that later okay
when just grab their business on cam I
just want to thank Mike hey everybody
I'm live streaming
I'm playing - yeah - come on do you
really want it hold on oh my god all
right how we look at this
[Music]